yo super fans thanks for joining us for
a very special game of Max guy demand
style as you know we always try to give
you the complete tool box you need to
build your man dreams as pros we have
some of the biggest and brightest tools
in the whole game and we're using those
tools to build our own man during we've
made a movie or film about our lives our
tools and how he became legends of
success this is the story behind the
story this is a three-hour
feature-length dramatic movie or film
called the blades edge the maxim gay
Gabe and Mac Mac's engage max story and
it's all true have some popcorn and
enjoy it someone once said to truly know
a man you must know everything about him
and his life but how can you know you
know it all you could ask him but he
might lie instead make him show you
from their troubled youths you'll never
have man style to that fateful first
meeting all the time it's crazy how some
people just don't care about having
men's yeah it makes me crazy too I care
so much about a man style it makes me
crazy I'm Gabe by the way I'm max their
big break excuse me sir hair gel for
your hair pardon me we're more boots hey
you guys where the two presidents of
details the magazine and we were walking
here on our way to the big meeting with
the head of internet and we saw what
you're doing how would you like to be on
it the internet
the deal
breakdown and I was putting a bag of
makeup for touch-ups come on max these
guys aren't idiots hey no you're a
[ __ ] idiot you're [ __ ] idiot oh
you don't know you didn't [ __ ] know
right now they didn't see my name on it
right you're talking about the couscous
I brought it you [ __ ] knew it was
mine to dreamers who dream so big they
got their dream here's the keys to your
brand-new boat it's the best one they
make the drama damn it Gabe this isn't
worth map out of that max you hit me I
know I hit you snap the [ __ ] out of it
everyone take 50 get your [ __ ] ass
back over here put that fact makeup on
do it again thanks gaben max I have some
news to tell you and it's not about a
war or politics the news is that I'm
pregnant
are you ready
wow that movie about us is going to be
great I'm so glad we made it soon what
max means we haven't made it yet but
we're going to have made it we just need
your help please send six million
dollars if you want to see this movie
very soon otherwise you can't see the
rest of it thank you for enjoying and
for funding our major motion picture
please send your millions to this
address